[Musique]
9 heures
il ya un message on a entendu sur sur
tous les stands d'avoir une ambition
pour la réaliser des associations
collector qu'elle soit coopérative créée
pour répondre à les marchés pour
transférer la compétition scientifique
mais ça chauffe d'avenir de plage en
france il ya aujourd'hui des
opportunités de marché comme jamais une
explosion de la demande alimentaire
mondiale
en même temps sur le marché intérieur
une demande qui a évolué une approche
plus sociétale avec nos compatriotes qui
attendent des produits mieux tracer un
souhait aussi de diminuer les intrants
les agriculteurs aujourd'hui ont la
possibilité de répondre à toutes à
toutes ces opportunités
il faut que les pouvoirs publics les
accompagnent dans ce sens les présidents
ont parlé au président jacob de
l'objectif qu'on avait de développer la
consommation des fruits et légumes qui
est un enjeu de santé publique et toutes
les actions qu'on fait concernant la
réduction de l'utilisation des
pesticides et le travail qui est fait au
centre technique interprofessionnel pour
trouver des alternatives dans des délais
raisonnables qu'on ne peut pas faire en
un an
il faut aussi les protéger parce qu'on
ne doit pas accepter des importations de
produits qui ne respecte pas les mêmes
normes que l'on exige à nos producteurs
sur le marché intérieur
la règle doit s'appliquer à tous ça veut
dire aussi plus d'europe
et puis une vraie ambition et c'est ça
qui manque aujourd'hui on le voit sur le
budget agricole
un président qui ne s'est pas mobilisé
un gouvernement qui ne s'est pas battu
et on est effectivement en difficulté en
ce moment il ya moins de 60 ans on est
formé beaucoup sur la russie il ya
quelques temps rien
république qui a fait quelques jours
voilà cabinet sanctions fermes et
résultat ils sont dix balles au dur nous
mêmes et en quelques années ils ont
produit l'équivalent de la production de
la france à l'expo ce qui met le feu
dans nos campagnes c'est qu'on est
victime d'une taxation américaine alors
que nous sommes pour rien sur le
problème de fond l'état français et
airbus ont été condamnés et la taxation
arrive sur le vin français et donc pour
les producteurs de vin en fait ils sont
punis d'un crime qu'ils n'ont pas commis
et ça ça reste en travers de la gorge et
donc ce que nous le montrer clair seront
des actions des députés auprès du
gouvernement pour dire qu'il ya urgence
et qu'on doit aider notre secteur les
agriculteurs sont fait part aux
décisions récentes que celles réalisant
sur les zones de l'entraînement et qui a
fait le choix de mettre en place des
distances le soleil ne sera pas possible
de plus non plus que compensé commune
ans s'est fait retirer alors ça va 2 020
fera à la 7 % selon les agriculteurs ma
chance dans beaucoup de bruit qui dit à
venir c'est d'arrêter d'exporter de se
replier sur nous-mêmes ne faire que du
bio et vous allez voir tout tout va bien
aller non je n'en savais une vraie
catastrophe
l'engagement qui est le nôtre qui est
celui des républicains c'est d'ailleurs
de porter la voix des agriculteurs et de
les accompagner pour répondre à ses
ambitions et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes mobilisés sur un forum spécifique
nous allons travailler pendant plus d'un
an sur agriculture et alimentation
on a besoin de vous les gras mais on y
est
les premières séances et au revoir